talking to high availability braintree
i'm a software developer
uh you know feel free to ask me
questions about braintree after the
conference or after the talk if you're
interested in the things that i
don't cover so braintree we're a payment
gateway what that means is we
essentially have software to process
payments through mostly online or mobile
applications
uh generally we deal with credit cards
so these are some of our merchants
so the idea with braintree is like if
you go to github.com and you want to pay
for service
you type in your credit card info you
hit submit that credit card
info stuff comes to us and we do all the
payments related stuff so we charge the
cards we move the funds at night
we do tokenization so you can get back a
token and charge the card later without
having to store credit card details
so pretty much all of that all the
payments related stuff behind these
sites essentially
is us so
you know the question why is uptime
important to us we do roughly 10 billion
in processing at our current estimates
that comes out to be about 19 000 a
minute
so you know downtime is extremely costly
for our merchants
and besides just like the you know the
raw
cost for them and for us obviously we
take fees on this stuff
you know you may not know that a lot of
those merchants use braintree so if
we're down
and you go to check out at a site you
may get an error you may get like your
credit card's not valid when actually it
is valid
so you know we would make those sites
kind of look bad because you don't you
know we're behind the scenes you don't
know that those sites use braintree most
of them we're not like paypal where you
have like the pay with paypal button
we're more of like a silent partner so
you know downtime just makes
everyone that we work with look bad and
it loses them a ton of money very
quickly so we care
we care very deeply about uptime
so people talk a lot about uptime not a
lot of people know you know exactly what
the numbers kind of mean
so this this chart from wikipedia kind
of trimmed down it's pretty interesting
uh you know people kind of throw out
five nines as a target five nines is
extremely difficult
it's five minutes a year so if your
primary database crashes and you take
some kind of manual work to bring it
back up
you know that takes ten minutes let's
say you've blown five nines for the
whole year
um you know 26 seconds a month it's
almost nothing
i would say at braintree we're probably
closer to four nines we strive for five
but probably closer to four
although our uptime is actually really
hard to manage or sorry to measure
um due to some of this i'm going to talk
about later just we have a lot of kind
of pieces and players involved and so
it's hard to know exactly what our
uptime is for different merchants
um but yeah this just just to give you
an idea like five nines is
unbelievably difficult
okay so this talk i'm gonna cover three
main causes of downtime
planned maintenance so this is we know
we need to do something to the site or
to our infrastructure we're going to do
something
on purpose there's unplanned failure you
know parts of our infrastructure fail or
things that we depend on will fail and
then basically people mistakes people
doing stuff that they shouldn't have
done
causing problems okay so
plan downtime this is you know reducing
our maintenance windows
so for us the biggest thing we do the
biggest maintenance window we have is
code deploys we're
a fast-moving company we're constantly
deploying new versions of things
you know these are typically kind of
maintenance windows
so braintree the main gateway started as
a pretty typical ruby on rails app about
four years ago so ran on my sql
it used apache passenger just kind of
the typical stuff you would have seen
from a few years ago
so the way we would generally deploy
that time is we would put up a
maintenance page
we would deploy our code out you know
switch it all over to the new stuff
we would run all of our database
migrations so again like a fast moving
company fast moving code base we would
constantly change our database schema
and then we would take down the
maintenance page so for this we're
basically down for the entire time that
we're deploying the code which is very
quick you know just moving sim links
mostly
and then running database migrations and
those as we would grow would get slower
and slower over time
and so at a certain point like these
day-to-day migrations were just
overwhelming like we were down for
noticeable months of time it was a
really big problem
so one of the first things we did kind
of in the early days was we switched
from bicycle to postgresql
so postgres ddl migrations are extremely
fast
you can add add you know add rename edit
columns extremely quickly in my sql
mysql would you know copy the entire
table if you want to add a column
and so as your table start growing and
getting very big you know the time to
copy a table gets larger and larger
until it's minutes
i mean i've been on projects where my
sequel migrations took hours
so you know and and your site is
basically unusable at that time so
postgres on the other hand extremely
fast we're talking millisecond
operations for all this stuff
uh similarly you can also add indexes
and postgres really quickly so postgres
gives you this keyword concurrently
which lets you add indexes without
locking tables with mysql
we would try to add indexes the tables
would lock the site basically becomes
unusable
postgres largely unnoticeable it takes a
little bit extra cpu because it does
like two scans of the table
but you can do it while the site's up
and with pretty much no impact and then
the other big one was
postgres lets you wrap ddl migrations in
a transaction
so we use rails we use rails migrations
you know if your migration has 10
statements in it and the first five runs
successfully and then the sixth one
fails
your database is in a pretty bad state
and you have to usually either manually
try to roll it back or manually finish
the migration to get to a state where
you can
run the code again and so with postgres
you can wrap the migrations in a
transaction if it fails in the middle
the whole thing rolls back you're back
to the previous date you just put back
the old code and keep going
so you're not in this state where you
can't run the app anymore
and this i actually did a whole
presentation on just this topic um if
you're interested you can check out the
slides it's
the migration wasn't super simple but
it's it's very doable
um and you know we did it with that with
very little downtime as well
okay so given that we moved to postgres
now our new
deploy process is while the site's up
while we're running kind of the old
stuff we add new tables and columns so
we kind of get ready
so like these like i said these are
super fast millisecond operations we get
all the new schema stuff ready
and then we roll out the code server by
server so at an app server time we put
out new code
and we restart so again no downtime here
because we're doing one at a time
and then once and then one side's fully
on the new code then we can go back and
add all the indexes and all the things
we discovered with how new usage
patterns work
and we go back into that and this and
this has no downtime right we
we've done everything we can while the
site's up we put out the code server by
server
no down time so this is kind of what it
looks like for the migrations and rails
so people familiar with rails
rails gives you a db migrate task we
basically added two new ones migrate pre
and migrate post
we use the same rails code we just
pointed different folders
so now any migrations you put in the
migrate prefolder will run before
you know the code is out and any
migrations in the post will run
afterwards
so it's pretty pretty straightforward
okay so one problem with this is that
rails caches columns
so when rails starts up it interrogates
the database and it
caches the set of columns for every
table so what this means is you can't
actually delete columns
so even if your code is no longer using
a column if you try to delete it rails
will still send the same statements with
the column in it oftentimes and then
you'll get these errors like column does
not exist
so what we wanted was basically array a
way to tell rails to forget the column
and so we added it so it looks like this
so on our models and rails we just add a
method called deleted columns you list
out all the columns you no longer want
to use
this is implemented behind the scenes
with some kind of alias method chaining
stuff for people that are familiar with
it
basically we overwrite the columns
method in rails in activerecord
and we strip out all the columns you
told us to delete
so now after we deploy we put out the
new code with this deleted columns code
in there
rails you know when it restarts it
doesn't even know about the column
doesn't do
included in any queries and then we can
get in the post migrations we can then
drop old columns that we're no longer
using
and usually we we don't usually drop
columns right away we usually delay a
release
giving us the ability to roll back one
so we let's say we're no longer using a
column
we'll add the delete a column line
deploy that and then the next release in
the post migration will drop the column
so we can always roll back at least one
release because if you drop the column
right away and you try to roll back then
you have old code which needs a column
and the column's not there
so we generally delay one
okay so one thing i talked about a
little bit but didn't really go into yet
is that we actually run multiple
versions of the code at once
as we're doing the server by server
deploy one at a time for that you know
several minutes that we're doing that we
have the old code running on some app
servers and the new code running on
others
it turns out that that's actually fine
for most features like most things we do
are additive
you know some new feature will show up
maybe and not show up for like a moment
and come back or
we're changing it back in integration
and we'll start sending a new flag and
then but some requests won't have it yet
it turns out it's generally okay for for
places that it's not okay
we use a lot of feature switches so we
have the ability to turn things on for
one merchant or kind of globally
so with a lot of new features we'll
deploy it dark we'll get it all out
there make sure the site is fine
otherwise and then we'll turn on a
feature for just one merchant and we'll
watch it so we'll work with like beta
merchants for different features
and then we can watch the traffic watch
how it's doing we can turn it back off
if there's
a problem if it's going well we turn it
on for more merchants and eventually we
roll it out across the board
for things that aren't really merchant
specific that are more global we just
have global switches too so again we can
roll off features dark and then just
turn them on globally
and then once things have been out for a
long time and we know we're not going to
turn them back off we'll just remove the
switches just to kind of clean up
so we do we do this a lot we feature
switch almost all
new features just as a way to reduce
risk as well like we can put things out
know that they won't affect anything and
then turn them on and watch them
those you know also preventing the
ability you know the need to roll back
because rolling back is pretty
pretty large probably you know pretty
large hammer essentially to hit
something with
so you generally we want to just use
switches to turn these on and turn them
back off
so that's what i described is pretty
much the way we do 95 percent of our
deploys today we do them almost all
server by server
but there are some limitations with that
approach so
a big one is column renames so we can
add columns in a
pre-migration we can now drop them in a
post migration with the deleted stuff
but you can't really rename columns it's
really hard to rename a column while the
site's up because you need
you'd somehow need the code to know
about both the old name and the new name
and then understand when to switch over
it's just it's really difficult so we
just generally don't do it
there's other maintenance tasks like
database failover so that what i've
showed is works really well for code
deploys
but if we need to like take down our
primary database for security upgrades
just like that
you know nothing i've really talked
about handles this case and then just
other infrastructure similar to
databases there's lots of work we want
to do in our data center that requires
us moving like taking a primary load
balancer out or taking a primary
you know database out and nothing really
covers that so what we essentially
really wanted was a way to pause traffic
something that would allow us to do
other types of issues other types of
maintenance
without downtime and so that's that's
what we built
so this is what our architecture looks
like today
heavily simplified obviously so we have
um
you know we have a load balancing layer
coming into multiple apaches
i've drawn two here there's you know
more than two and then it goes to
something called the broxy which i'll go
into this is something we wrote
and then the proxy feeds into a redis
queue so we use an in-memory queue
in redis and then we have the
dispatchers reading out of redis
so the piece to note here is basically
put a redis queue in the middle of our
request processing
so the proxy it stands for braintree
proxy we're not we're not very clever
about naming
so it's a python tornado app so at the
time we wrote this which is it's been a
few years now we kind of looked around
for what to write it in
we're generally pretty polyglot at
braintree and we wanted something that
was very efficient
and it's kind of easy easy to write so
what this app is doing is it's taking
every request it's just shuffling
requests around so we like the idea of
something invented because it's going to
hold tons of open connections it's just
moving data around
it's very lightweight um at the time we
looked tornado
just seemed really nice it was running
you know with friend feed and
uh facebook is running a production it
has some really nice built-in testing
stuff so we decided to kind of go with
it
so like i said it accepts web requests
from apache and then all it does is it
bundles them up and puts them into a
redis queue so it takes
the body the headers pretty much
everything that comes in that request
puts it in a message and puts it in
redis and then on the way back it reads
out of a response redis cue and then it
responds back to the web request
so it's just feeding into redis and then
responding back out
so the dispatchers on the other side so
these are lightweight rack adapters
so for those who don't know rack is like
a ruby web server framework i guess
it's like all pretty much all the ruby
web servers now
adhere to a rack interface so the
dispatcher is a rack interface that
basically
integrates with rails so it takes the
request from redis
and then it processes them through rails
so we still use rails we just do it via
queue instead of a web server
and then it takes the response uh sorry
then it after it gets the response from
rails it puts it back into redis and it
goes back out to the proxy
so the dispatcher part looks like this
essentially
it's it's a ruby script we basically
load uh rail's root config environment
so at this point we have rails loaded we
have all the code available to us
and then we build our own rack app but
we use the action controller dispatcher
so we're building a rack app but we're
really using all of rail's code right we
don't really want to rewrite a web
server essentially so we're going to use
all the rail stuff
so then in a big loop we just pull the
request out of redis
and we build a rack request so rack
request is just a big hash of pretty
much everything rack needs
here i've shown two elements but there's
there's like 10
including the uri body headers pretty
much everything and then the last line
you see there we just do app.calls so
this
process through the whole rails stack we
go through all the middlewares pretty
much everything that rails normally does
for web server we just do
through this rack adapter and then once
we get the response we just turn that
back into a string
and then put it back in redis we put
back the status the body we put the
headers a bunch of other stuff
and we just send it back out so that
looks like this again
so now we want to suspend traffic all we
have to do is stop dispatchers
so we stopped the dispatchers the entire
top half of the half of the stack is
still working requests are coming in
they're in queueing
there's just nothing processing them and
since the dispatchers aren't running
nothing's using the database nothing's
using like our search servers pretty
much
everything in the bottom is unused so we
can do any kind of maintenance we want
we can
push out new code we can rename columns
we can do database failover pretty much
anything we want
and then when we're done we just restart
the dispatchers they clear out the queue
and everyone's happy so the users will
see
long requests but they won't see failed
requests and in general we feel like
that's
a better trade-off you know today people
have gotten pretty conditioned like if
you hit submit on a payment form
like you know sometimes it's going to
take a little while so instead of seeing
a two second request you'll see
a 20 second request but you'll still get
the proper request
or the proper response and that's and
that's pretty important
um and so as long as we can keep our
maintenance to around 20 or 30 seconds
that's kind of our
our window we can just do everything
without getting timeouts
so another you know another nice thing
is we provide client libraries so people
integrate with braintree through our
client libraries
so we know what the timeouts are we can
we can control the timeouts we can make
sure that the amount of time we keep the
dispatchers down for is less than the
timeouts at the top level
we control the proxy timeouts so we
basically know exactly how long we have
at every step
in our stack to do the kind of work we
need to do
and so we can you know we basically can
do a lot of work in 20 to 30 seconds
um you know like i said any kind of
failover we use this
technique to switch data centers at one
point where we actually move traffic
from one data center to another
um with a pause and not without losing
traffic so this works it works pretty
well
so just to summarize this section we
basically do
pre and post migrations we do as much
work as we can while the site's up
reducing risk also you know no downtime
and then we do rolling deploys for
nearly every deploy
we roll out code server by server
restart things you know keep the site up
as much as possible
we use postgres because it's really fast
at doing a lot of database work
we really like postgres in general it's
a great database and then for everything
where we can't do that we use the proxy
and that's
every kind of maintenance where we
actually need to just pause traffic to
get something
something larger done essentially
okay so that's that's plan failure
that's how we do the stuff we know we
need to do
then there's a whole set of unplanned
failure right servers fail
you know networks go down it's pretty
common
it you know essentially the unexpected
happens and all we can really do is
you know do our best to be resilient so
we try to build resilient systems such
that it can handle even
unexpected issues so start with server
failure
pretty typical way to handle silver
failure is load balancing this is in
this case we're no different
we build our own load balancers though
so that is actually pretty different
in general at braintree we just really
we like components that are
simple and easy to understand so we tend
to shy away from
black boxes and so load bouncers are a
giant kind of black
black box appliance um you know they
work well for some people
they also people love to complain about
them i mean if you you hear lots of
horror stories about like f5s and stuff
like that
so we prefer just to kind of build our
own we understand it at every level we
can tune it for availability for
security we can tweak it to our needs
so we just really like to control it so
what we use is we use
lvs or ipvs this is the linux virtual
server project or ipv virtual server
it's basically kernel level routing so
our load balancers are just linux
servers
traffic comes into them and then via
kernel level rules the traffic gets
routed to other backends
so it's pretty simple we manage a
cluster of them with pacemaker so it
handles failover if a load balancer dies
and then we have two components that we
wrote called big brother and limits
paper and i'll go into these in a moment
so this is you know the the diagram of
what it looks like so traffic comes in
either externally or internally we load
bounce a lot of internal services
it goes to a virtual ip living on one
load bouncer um each load balancer has
many ips for all the different services
and then the load balancer forwards the
traffic to back end in this case apaches
and the piece to note is that big
brother runs in the load balancer and
litmus paper runs on the back end
so big brother it's a ruby apple road it
like i said runs in load bouncers its
job is just to check the status of the
back ends
so every second it's just pulling back
end servers getting you know the status
of how they're doing
and then it updates ipvs rules so if it
discovers the back end's down or not
responding it updates the kernel level
rules to change the routing such that
new traffic won't flow
won't flow there and so it's just doing
that constantly it's just in a big loop
and big brother's open source you can
check it out on our github
so on the other side is litmus paper
limits paper is also ruby app
it's the piece that big brother is
querying via http
and the idea is with with limits paper
is it's a consistent interface that big
brother can query
so it runs on all of our back ends and
it returns a health level and
its job is to kind of map between
whatever it needs to do
to that health level so for an apache
server it probably just turns around and
curls apache
and if it patches up then it says i'm up
and then it combines that with
you know system level info so if the
load is high but apache is up maybe the
health isn't 100 it's
80. if it's totally down the health is
zero that kind of stuff so
limits paper just figures out what it
needs to do for that server for that
type and it returns a health level to
big brother
and this is also open source you can
check it out so there's the diagram
again
so like i said big brother is just
querying the back ends litmus papers
responding with the healths
and then based on big brother rules the
the load balancer will forward or not
forward traffic to those back ends
so it's pretty it's pretty
straightforward okay so that works
really well for stateless services
things like apache where you can send
traffic to three different apaches and
then if one you know goes down you just
send it to two apaches instead
we also have a class of state full
servers where you can't just send
all of your traffic to all of them so
load balancers are one of them you know
the virtual ip lives on one load
balancer
postgres is another big one so we have
you know primaries and standbys you
can't send all of your
traffic to all of your postcard servers
you need the rights to go to the
primaries
and just try to send right to the
standbys you'll get errors so for these
we use pacemaker to manage failover
so pacemaker just kind of manages a
cluster of things so it manages a
cluster of our postgres
it keeps track of which one's primary
which one's standby if the primary fails
pacemaker will do the failover for us
and they'll promote the standby
and then we just move virtual ips so the
app
just knows the virtual ip of like the
database the virtual ip of search the
virtual pa pretty much everything
and then when things die either the
unbounce or pacemaker will
move them and then the virtual ip just
moves along with it so we don't need to
reconfigure anything when things die
okay so that's server failure now we
have network failure
so fun site to look at internetpulse.com
it shows you
basically outages between different isps
internet service providers across the
internet
so i took this screenshot last week it
turns out that issues in isps are
actually very common
so you can see like um at the top you
can see the red box is between
centurylink and savis
so if you're running a service on status
and you're trying to connect to it from
your home which is centurylink let's say
you might have trouble connecting you
can see like there's
there's a lot of isp issues one of the
things i learned at braintree is that
it's like network issues are actually
very common it's amazing sometimes if
the internet actually works
because there are so many issues just
with connections across the wire
so pretty much if we see connection
issues we'll pull up this site and you
can kind of
we know which isps we serve out of which
data centers and you can kind of look at
the different connection issues with
other isps
okay so we have two kinds of networking
i want to talk about here so the first
one is inbound this is
a merchant wants to charge a credit card
so they make an api call to us so that's
inbound coming to us so for that we use
bgp
to route traffic through multiple isps
and data centers
so bgp is the border gateway protocol
it's essentially the protocol of the
internet
so it you know use dns to go from a name
to an ip address
so bgp is how you figure out where to go
with that ip address
so our routers participate in bgp they
broadcast
you know the ips that we handle and then
bgp handles like finding the best path
through the internet to get to us so if
an isp goes down
bgp will essentially unbalance it and
then it'll find another route to us
so in general bgp does shortest route
with some caveats
but if the route is down it'll find a
new route that's you know the one that's
up
so by participating in this you know we
have multiple paths coming into us
so depending on where the merchant is
where the customer is
the traffic will route to us via
different isps and different data
centers
and then we use monitoring services we
use pingdom pretty heavily and we use
our own kind of servers that we
scattered throughout the world
and we basically just do that to monitor
it so bgp is great it unbalances it it
works
but it's not always instantaneous we've
seen issues where especially when isp
outages are partial
we've seen issues where we see a lot of
problems coming in via one route
but bgb hasn't figured it out yet or
hasn't fully unbalanced
so since we have our own monitoring we
can kind of detect these cases and then
we just manually yank the bgp routes
and force the traffic over a different
path
so that's kind of how we so bcp
generally does its own thing it works
but we also
can do it manually if we need to based
on our own monitoring
okay so that's trouble coming to us we
also have the problem we
we are not the end point for most of
this traffic we need to go out
across the network to actually tell
whether their credit cards are valid or
whether they have enough money on that
so in general we don't we don't talk
about visa directly we talk to
what are called like merchant fires of
costing networks in general
so for people that know payments we
talked about like chase payment attack
thesis versus data
uh we talked to international talk a lot
of things directly
because we need essentially we need to
get back to whoever whichever issue bank
issues
to know if you have money on my credit
card so
if like if i leave here with a ton of
these coffee numbers but we need to
basically make outbound calls to them
so you may call to us we need to turn
around and make another call to figure
out
how much is available on this card and
so like i said the isp outages are very
are usually partial
it's rare that you have a total outage
it does happen i think last year there
was a construction in chicago and they
just
drilled right to the line like one of
the big issues in chicago and took out
the entire thing
but generally like a router fails
somewhere or there's some packet loss
so they're not usually full outages so
we've gotten into cases where
we have multiple isps but we can't reach
every endpoint we have to hit
on all of our xps so it's not like we
can say like oh we're having problems
with this one let's just take it out
we'll use the other one
maybe they're both having partial
outages and we can only reach some on
one and some on the other
and so we really wanted was a way to
choose an isp
for the end point we're trying to get to
so some are better than others for
certain paths we want to use the best
one for that path
and so we built our processor proxies
that's what we call them so instead of
the dispatcher connecting directly we
connect through a proxy
we run one proxy per endpoint so per
processor like we have one one for chase
let's say
pinned to a specific isp and then we can
load balance over them so if there are
issues we can we
allow our load balancing to take them
out
and this allows us to route around
issues on isps that are
partial essentially so the piece we
wrote to this is called mallory
it's also pilot tornado for the same
reasons it's just shoveling traffic back
and forth we find something very
lightweight
it proxies requests and this is a big
one so we looked around you know we
didn't essentially we didn't
want to write our own proxy but we kind
of looked around what was out there
and you know ssl verification is a big
it's kind of a big deal so ssl does
encryption
but it also does verification which is
you want to know that the end point
you're connected to is actually who you
think it is so most of the processing
networks use ssl
um and a lot of proxies will will do ssl
encryption but they don't have to do
verification so they'll ensure that your
traffic's encrypted
but not that you're connecting to who
you think you're connecting to and so
one of the things we do is
we strongly you know verify the sl
certificate so we can't get man in the
middle
so if somehow we were to get man in the
middle of upstream our request would
fail rather than send credit card data
to the wrong person
um and then we would we would notice
that our requests are failing we would
look into it
so it's really it's really unfortunate
that if you look online and you look at
you kind of google this
a lot of recommendations online are oh
just turn off sl encryption right curl
dash k like just turn it off
but i mean ssl is very powerful and you
should definitely use it
as much as possible even with
verification
so the other cool thing with mallory
another reason we wrote it is it acts
like limits paper
so the same way big brother is querying
litmus paper big brother can directly
query mallory
so mallory is doing the proxing and it's
keeping track of how that proxy is going
and then if the last few requests
haven't gone so well when big brother
queries it you can say like actually
proxy's not going that well i'm gonna
return to low health or zero health
saying that this route is just not good
right now
and mallory is also open source you can
check it out so this is kind of what the
diagram looks like
so the dispatcher is trying to make a
call to the processor on the right
it you know makes a call through a
virtual ip that's load balanced over two
mallories each mallory is pinned to an
isp
in that data center and then the traffic
will eventually route there so if
the isp1 goes down the top mallet will
unbalance and traffic will flow through
the bottom mallory
and this you know this works when we
look at the logs we see mallory's kind
of unbalancing periodically of today
like
little issues will happen but we
generally survive them without without
really noticing
so connection fails we do get connection
failures right
the way we know that a route is bad is
we will get a connection failure trying
to talk
over it so this is something we do have
to deal with our general
our general practice is we just let
things heal so in the case of mallory
we get a connection failure we know that
when big brother goes to query it will
unbalance it so we just let the system
heal
with things like the database we know
that pacemaker will handle the failover
so we just wait like we just wait for it
to handle the issue
and then we retry and we do retrying at
a lot of different levels of our stack
so in the case of processor calls we'll
often do several
two or three if we can't connect knowing
that if there's an issue mallory will
unbalance and then we'll reroute around
it
uh with things like the database if our
database our primary database were to
crash
we would we would lose the request in
flight there's you know
that's not what we can do about that but
before our dispatchers pick up another
request from redis
they do heartbeats and so they won't
pick up a request until they can
actually check that the whole app is
working again
and that means that the database has to
fully fail over the noon has to come up
then the heartbeat to start working and
then the dispatchers will pick up the
requests again
and so this is the way we kind of retry
there so we we won't pick up requests if
we know that things are busted we'll
wait until things have healed and then
start processing again
okay so just to summarize kind of the
unplanned failures load balancing we do
for
server failure and also kind of
components of network failure
we have redundancy across isps inbound
we use bgp
for routing outbound we use processor
proxies to kind of target the right isp
for the right endpoint
and then in general we just let things
heal and then try again and we do like i
said we do retrying at many different
levels of our stack
okay so the last section people make
mistakes
um it's it's inevitable right people can
cause outages you run the wrong command
you do the wrong thing
you cause an outage people can also make
things worse
you know let's say there's already an
outage and you just take a long time
fixing it or you run a command to try to
figure out what's going on and you just
make the outage worse
so you know people people can be a
problem
so here's a couple examples the big ec2
outage of 2011
they say that the traffic shift was
executed incorrectly so you know that
someone there just you know probably ran
the wrong set of commands
github outage also a few years ago
this one due to configuration error they
accidentally dropped their production
database rather than their test database
and had to then go restore their
production database from a backup and i
believe they were down for a good chunk
of that time
so that one you know they just ran the
wrong command in the wrong environment
pagerduty had an outage this this year
uh this one's really interesting they
actually call out due to the engineers
being extremely tired and burned out
after working for the night on the
upgrades
so this is i mean this is very common
right you have an issue you're working
on it all night
you're just more likely to make mistakes
once you're tired and i don't mean to
call these companies i think it's great
that these companies are so open that
they can publish these post-mortems and
then we can all as a community learn
from it
you know my point is just that every
company has people issues and everyone
will make mistakes at some point
so the so the goal is just kind of
reducing these mistakes you can't
entirely prevent them
so we just want to we want to reduce the
factor we know we can't get rid of it
entirely
so one of the big things we do is we
automate everything or as close to
everything as we can
so automation reduces errors right like
you're if you're running an automated
command it's less likely you'll forget
the wrong
command line flag or something dumb you
know you're more likely to run the right
thing at the right time
it also gives confidence that things
still work so you know like i said we're
a fascinating company infrastructure's
changing maybe the way you unbalance the
service
a month ago isn't the same way you
unbalance it today maybe the set of
commands have changed
if you rely on automation then when
things change the automated tasks will
change and then you know that when you
run the unbalanced command it will do
whatever the right set of things are
today to do the task you want
so over time you know that it's going to
do the right thing and you don't have to
worry about
hey what's the way i do this you know
how do i do this today versus how did i
do it a month ago
and then in general just speeds things
up right we have these proxy pauses for
20 30 seconds
you know if we have to do a lot of work
in there like you know complicated
failovers we don't want to
have the person typing commands and
hitting enter like we need to run those
very quickly and automation just takes
care of that
um just in general like the the less
you're in production the less likely you
are to make a mistake
so automation means less time in
production
and our tools are kept strong with
puppet so we use puppet to manage server
configs so we know that
every server is set up the same way or
in a consistent way so so you you know
that
the unbalance on one server is the exact
same as the unbounce on another because
both boxes were set up with puppet and
then we orchestrate everything through
capistrano
so all of our deploys all of our
failovers unbalancing we pretty much
have tasks for pretty much everything we
want to do
in production in in all of our
environments really
okay so besides automation we also add a
lot of safeguards
so one big one is dangerous tasks just
don't run a production so if you want to
drop a database like you would do in
test all the time
you try to run that in production it
just fails it says like you know we use
the environment to know like you can't
run some production doesn't blow up on
you
so we try to prevent you know the github
issue of dropping the wrong database
and so we have lots of dangerous things
like this that just won't run in certain
environments
we also add um the pr we also the
environment name to the prompt
so on your terminal line you're typing
commands at the beginning of your
line it says in red letters production
or if you're in a test environment
you'll say green letters test or
something like that
so as you're typing commands you know
you're looking right where that turn
where
you're typing you see in big red letters
production so you know exactly what
environment you're working in
and this is really helpful when you're
working in multiple environments you
know maybe you're testing something out
in tests but then running it in
production you're switching back and
forth
you know you want to know which ones are
in tests and which ones are in
production and we just put that right in
the prompt
we also have read-only databases and
logs so if you're you know interrogating
somebody trying to figure something out
you don't have to worry about
accidentally running a bad query you
know one year read-only you can't
destroy anything and two you're doing
read-only on a database that's not even
in the main you know database
in the data center so even if you were
to run a query that didn't modify
anything but was super slow and brought
down the database so you don't have to
worry about it
same thing with logs we you know you're
we look at logs on log servers that are
shipped out of our main
center so if you were to run a really
expensive graph and slow down the box
like you don't have to worry about
actually slowing down production
at that so basically just try to shield
you as much as possible from the actual
running software
and then the other thing is monitoring
so we use nagios pretty extensively
so we use so nagios monitors everything
from like the load on a box
uh uptime to we write a lot of custom
checks like did the nightly settlement
job finished successfully
um did we bill all the subscriptions
that we're supposed to build did we miss
any things like that we have a lot of
checks just at all levels we have that
hooked up to pagerduty so it'll call you
so a check fails it calls you so if
you're working in production you
generally have nagios open
and you have page duty set up to you so
if you do something
and something goes wrong you immediately
get a phone call and you know that you
did something and you're right there
ready to fix it
and then we also have this multi-app log
tail so our general way we use tmux we
split vertically
you know generally one side is the
command you're running the other side is
just a log
and we have a script that takes the logs
from multiple apps puts them together
strips them down to just the important
parts and colors them so you'll see like
greens for
you know http successes reds for
failures we also color by response
time and we show the total time and the
app time separately so you'll know if
the total time is really high but the
app time is low there's a queuing issue
and we just have this thing kind of
scrolling and because our apps are
pretty busy
these days we added sampling so maybe
you only want to look at three percent
of the traffic just so it's a reasonable
amount and you see these logs
if you're doing something and all of a
sudden you see red out of the corner of
your eye start to go you know you did
something wrong
you're right there you can fix it very
quickly you don't have to wait for
something else to happen
so like i said you can't always prevent
the error but the idea is catching it
really quickly and trying to fix it
before it becomes a really big issue
and then we use graphite immunity for
graphing we started with munin we're
moving most ever
most of our stuff to graphite now we
don't really alert on this stuff but
it's more like if you're doing some kind
of work let's say you're running a big
database load
you'll pull up the graphs for like the
database i o and the database boxes and
you'll kind of watch them
so if you see crazy spikes you know that
probably something's wrong and you can
act on it
so this is more just like you know
you're doing something and you want to
watch it we also have dashboards in the
offices and stuff like that
but just you want to keep an eye on what
you're doing so that if you do cause a
problem you can find it very quickly
and that's pretty much it so to
summarize that just automation pretty
much automated everything
reduce errors with safeguards just to
try to prevent people from doing the
wrong thing as much as possible and
when you're running commands to know the
environment you're running them in
and then just as much monitoring as we
can you know we have the monitoring that
opens at night so that you get a call if
something fails at night but then also
just keeping an eye on the monitoring
while you're doing work so that you know
if you cause a problem
and that's it thank you